[Música]
vamos ahora a contextualizar lo que está
pasando en kenia tras las elecciones
generales de ese país donde millones de
ciudadanos fueron a las urnas para
elegir al próximo presidente de esa
nación que todavía pues no conocemos los
resultados se tiene previsto que se
conozcan entonces la semana que viene
pero antes de presentar a los dos
candidatos y analizar el contexto en que
se desarrollaron todos estos comicios
generales cruciales veamos algunos datos
sobre ese país de áfrica del este por
supuesto con nuestra periodista
especializada en áfrica amal benotman
ama la bienvenida para nosotros es un
gusto que nos acompañe esta mañana de
miércoles entonces empecemos digamos con
estos datos básicos sobre que ella si
era un la población keniana de unos 54
millones de personas es mayoritariamente
joven y cristiana la capital del país es
nairobi y los idiomas que se hablan son
principalmente el inglés y el swahili el
país raúl cuenta además con más de 40
grupos étnicos los principales siendo
los kikuyu los louie a los lugo y los
kalenjin
si tiene más información al si bueno
ahora podemos hablar de los candidatos
los de los principales candidatos para
estas elecciones entonces entonces
empecemos con a raila odinga raúl este
hombre de 77 años es un histórico
opositor sin embargo desde el 2018 se
convirtió en un aliado del jefe de
estado saliente uhuru kenyatta es un
veterano de la política que pasó nueve
años detenido tras un golpe de estado
fallido en
1982 y es la quinta vez que se presenta
para ser presidente con un programa
centrado en la reconciliación nacional y
el bienestar social
una victoria raúl de raila odinga podría
ser considerada como su revancha
política y es que como candidato en el
2007 perdió al hacer las presidenciales
tras las manipulaciones electorales que
llevaron a la reelección del entonces
presidente mwai kibaki y que sumieron a
quien ya en un baño sangre con más de
1000 personas muertas en violentos
enfrentamientos el rival de raila odinga
en estas elecciones es william ruto este
candidato de 55 años es vicepresidente
desde el 2013 y enemigo declarado de
uhuru kenyatta el presidente saliente su
trayectoria política es bastante
controvertida ya que la corta pena la
corte penal perdón internacional lo
acusó de crímenes contra la humanidad
tras los enfrentamientos postelectorales
de 2007 y además de esto se enfrentó a
casos de expropiación de tierras y de
corrupción durante su campaña ha buscado
los votos de los ciudadanos de a pie y
golpeados por la inflación y exasperados
por la corrupción y aunque ha sido la
mano derecha de un juro keniata durante
nueve años se ha presentado como un
hombre hecho a sí mismo con un destino
excepcional el del hijo de un campesino
que ha ascendido a la escala del poder
keniano dominado en gran medida por las
grandes dinastías políticas de las que
forman parte auguró keniata y raila
odinga
ahora esa mala hablemos entonces de este
contexto en el que llega el país a estos
comicios generales que como pues hasta
ahora no tenemos el ganador vamos a
contextualizar a nuestra audiencia de
cómo llega a que en estas elecciones
absolutamente era wheels y kenia es un
país de paradojas por un lado es un país
con la reputación de estabilidad en
áfrica oriental el motor económico de la
región y la séptima economía del
continente y por otro es un país
extremadamente desigual donde un tercio
de la población vive por debajo del
umbral de la pobreza como en el resto
del mundo la inflación se ha acelerado
en los últimos meses y en julio fue un
8,3 por ciento más alta que en la misma
época del año pasado lo que representa
un recorte en estos últimos cinco años
los precios de la harina la gasolina el
aceite para cocinar y otros productos
básicos se han casi duplicado en un año
golpeando a las clases populares y ya
debilitadas por la crisis del coronarios
además según el banco mundial desde el
año 2020 de la pandemia de kobe 19 la
tasa de desempleo subió hasta el 10,4
por ciento y casi 2 millones de kenianos
han caído de la pobreza a ello hay que
sumar la peor sequía en los últimos 70
años que ha dejado a 4,1 millones de
kenianos en situación de inseguridad
alimentaria y además de todo eso en los
últimos años el país invirtió invirtió
exageradamente según los observadores en
mega proyectos de infraestructuras y
corre ahora un alto riesgo de
endeudamiento según el fondo monetario
internacional
por lo tanto raúl es importante señalar
que quien sea elegido presidente hereda
de un país en el que la desesperación es
tal que la pregunta por cuanto se puede
vender un riñón es una de las más
formuladas por correo al hospital
nacional kenyatta según la prensa local
es bastante grave la situación ha mal en
kenia gracias por contextualizar lo pido
por favor que se quede con nosotros para
seguir profundizando sobre este tema con
nuestro segundo invitado el día gracias
a mal